i truly can't believe this is happening  the world health organization is warning  people  not to attack monkeys  because of monkey pox  if it weren't for what we saw during  covid  where  random asian americans were being  attacked  because of trump's rhetoric about the  china virus if it weren't for that  i would be saying nobody would be stupid  enough to attack a monkey because of  monkey pox would they and yet that is  exactly what the who is trying to  prevent now it's called monkey pox  because it's believed that at some  original point in the transmission  monkeys were a nexus  but the transmission that we are seeing  in the united states the tens of  thousands of cases that we are seeing  it's coming from people person to person  people are going out and attacking  monkeys guys what is wrong with humanity